حينها شنت قوه الناتو هجوما على
يوغوسلافيا استمر 78 يوما لتنتهي الحرب
بعد انسحاب القوات الصربيه ومنذ ذلك الوقت
تعمل قوات تابعه للحلف على حفظ السلام
هناك اصابع الاتهام الغربيه تشير الى
روسيا وتتهمها بدفع الوضع نحو التصعيد من
اجل الضغط على اوروبا الكرملين اعلنها
صراحه وقال ان موسكو تؤيد صربيا وحقوق
صربي كوسوفو بشكل كامل وغير مشروط
التوترات تتزايد يوما بعد يوم وحدتها وصلت
الى اعلان الرئيس الصربي الكسندر وضع جيش
بلاده في حاله تاهب قصوى مع تحرك وحداته
نحو الحدود القريبه مع كوسوفو مشاهد تعود
الى الاذهان صور النزاع العنيف في المنطقه
قبل اكثر من عقدين من الزمن بلال البجدين
العربيه لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات